this burrito is delicious but it is  feeling sorry in Spain they've made me  faint no offense  the moustache when women see me with a  moustache they're transported back to a  time when the moustache was king crying  citizen this isn't a moustache it's a  time machine  sixty percent of the time it's every  time just let me come in with my team  and our gear for a few days I don't see  your moustache okay I got it I got it is  everybody in this country is butt ugly  as you three I meant it as a compliment  I'm sorry Kate it like this why don't  you borrow a hold on you so don't let  this happen  welcome in the eye  I don't care what you think about this  this is not for you all great men have  mustaches  yeah but real manage to grow them have a  hormone disorder  do it